These days, we understand
a lot about human behavior.
For example,
our eyes are naturally drawn to motion.
If something is moving while
everything around it stays the same,
we're naturally drawn to
the thing that's moving.
This is a powerful tool in UI design,
really useful for directing
your user's attention to an important or
immediately relevant UI element.
But that's just the beginning.
We saw in lesson two, that shadows
can tell you a lot about a surface.
Well, how that surface moves can
actually tell you a whole lot about
it as well.
More specifically, an object's motion
can provide important cues about
how you could interact with it.
Let's take a look.
Take a look at this example of tabs.
Okay, now take a look at this one.
Can you tell the difference?
Here they are side by side.
In both cases pressing on the tab
at the top changes to that tab.
But, in the second example, a little
slide animation is used to switch tabs.
This subtle animation helps communicate
that you can actually swipe the tabs
to switch between them.
We call this instructive motion.
Without this kind of instructive motion,
it would be less likely that users
would discover this behavior,
as the spatial relationship
between pages would be less clear.
In this example, as the music
player controls move into view,
notice how the volume
control slides into place.
This animation provides a subtle cue
that the user can move the slider,
horizontally, along the track.
And remember in Lesson 2 how we talked
about the elevations of surfaces and
how they can imply what
happens upon scrolling?
Well changes in elevation could help
communicate changes in interaction.
When two surfaces are adjacent like here
at the same elevation they might move
together, but at some point one
surface might change its elevation
to communicate that it now moves
independently of the other one.
The way that content enters the scene
can also imply ways to interact with it.
In this example, the bottom sheet enters
from the bottom of the screen, implying
that it can be dragged upward or
dismissed by dragging it back downward.
In all these examples of instructive
motion, you can see that how something
moves can give you plenty of hints
about how you can interact with it.